life in the path of hs2 is precarious
this cable company in long eaton near
nottingham has lived with the prospect
of compulsory eviction for a decade
this whole site would become a
if you like a goods yard for the project
that threat may now be lifted but it's
already taken its toll on the business
the uncertainty is very much around
investment and what we do next but
knowing that we might have to move in
the next five years or so but
makes that quite difficult to do hs2 was
supposed to slash journey times between
london and the major cities of the north
less than a mile away is toten signings
the proposed site for a three billion
pound hub station
billed as the most connected place in
britain and a catalyst for investment in
thousands of new homes and businesses
that's now in doubt
this was supposed to be the heart of the
eastern leg of hs2 with a new line
carrying trains traveling at more than
200 miles an hour north and south but it
now seems likely the high speed line
will in fact stop down there south of
radcliffe on saw power station with
journeys north to leeds continuing on
existing track at slower speeds and with
less capacity
a promise new line between manchester
and leeds is also in peril leaving
northern leaders deeply concerned
will that amount to a betrayal of the
promises that have been made to the
north and indeed the whole concept of
leveling up i think
leveling up would be dealt uh an
extremely uh severe uh blow and uh it's
it's it's hard to see how
um beyond um beyond that uh
the whole concept would would be able to
mean something uh to to people
newspapers across the north of england
have united in calling on boris johnson
to keep his promises to commuters and
employers looking for evidence of
levelling up there's massive potential
in the northern cities and that will
that that's what will be throttled off
and choked off if we can't get more um
uh more uh people to be able to access
the cities that we've got
the government will finally confirm its
plans on thursday hopes for a rail
revolution may be permanently delayed
paul kelso sky news in totem